let's turn to the voice okay because
millions are gonna have their eyes on
the show it's back on Monday night but
that is not the reason that adam levine
and kelly clarkson are all over the news
no maroon 5 is playing the Super Bowl
BAM
and Kelly's talk show well it just
became official what doesn't kill you
makes you strong
you know that you were sitting next to
potentially the next Oprah Winfrey less
than two months after shooting her pilot
NBC just announced the Kelly Clarkson
show will debut a year from now if Adam
was your first guest on your potential
show okay what's doing one question
you'd ask it is what you were twerking
with being absolutely yeah I loved our
tour
[Music]
Kelly toured with maroon 5 in 2013 and
the band just booked a major gig
multiple sources tell ET maroon 5 is
scheduled to perform the halftime show
at the Super Bowl in February but up
next for Adam and Kelly they join J
Hutton Blake for the voices Blind
Auditions Monday on NBC and you know
what I'm just gonna get real and confess
if I had to turn my chair around for one
of the four coaches there's no
competition this is about to get real
awkward but Adam Levine is myself
Liberty crush even kidding you stop I'm
kidding I'm being completely honest I
don't know what it is but it's like you
shut up okay it's the chain it's the
glasses it's the mystery
oh he is fine and you know what I just
met his wife in an elevator at the
airport so biani I'm sorry for lusting
after you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]